i come from an entrepreneurial family my
grandparents
immigrated from north africa to france
same for my mother
my father built companies before so i
grew up into that always knew that i was
going to build companies it's in my soul
and in my vein
i'm alex bosies i'm an entrepreneur and
i'm the ceo and co-founder of teal
we help companies hire anyone anywhere
in a click of a button
having lived in different countries and
having an amazing co-founder that did
the same
she was born and raised in china and
paid our way through jobs at mit and
that's where i met her
when we went back home after that to
build our first companies we always
wanted to hire our friends
and hiring people from a country like
israel when they're back in the u.s is
very complicated
having run through that process and
understanding the value of talent and of
diversity within a team
we wanted to make it really easy for
anyone to do that today we're doing it
for
you know thousands tens of thousands
there's a much bigger goal
[Music]
you know the american dream for me is
the ability to come
into a country where you don't speak the
language where
you know when i think of my family i'm
sure that if they would have come to the
u.s instead of a country like france
they could have built
without taking anything away from them
quite a lot more and i come to the end
facing all those investors and those
amazing people that are just here
regardless of where you're from
regardless of who you are
they're willing to bet on you like like
no other
in my industry i would say try
and try harder don't stop because i mean
god knows i've tried and gotten those
have failed in in the past couple
companies
but what happens is when you keep on
digging you'll eventually find your
your golden nugget and if you keep on
working
you'll you'll get there no one else
believes in your dream and in
the work you're doing other than you and
if you're pushing you'll get there
you